the night went to the ruling party
prime minister kiriakos mitsutakis
calling the winning margin a political
earthquake
one student we spoke to was surprised at
the amount of support the party received
I expected them to be lower than last
time because of of the events of the of
the past few years
the tragedy that we had in tebi with a
with a rail with a with a train the
wildfires that happened in Greece the
the housing crisis as I mentioned before
the living costs crisis
the recent train disaster which caused
Mass protests and a controversial
wiretapping Scandal doing nothing it
seems to dance support
voting started at 7am where for the
first time 17 year olds could have their
say and another first Greeks living
abroad could vote from their country of
residence
the main concern here the impossibly
High Cost of Living
every year instead of improving things
are getting worse things are expensive
every day things are getting out of
control it's enough to make you afraid
to go to the supermarket to shop we'll
see how things go
I have low expectations because
unfortunately people don't understand
they vote for the same people over and
over again
Monday we'll see Greece's president ask
new democracy with forming a government
they have three days to do so and the
Mandate then passes on to the next party
if it fails
this vote took place under a system of
proportional representation and none of
the parties have enough seats to rule
alone
all have publicly stated however that
they won't work together it had already
been widely predicted before the vote
that a runoff election could be the
final scenario that will take place in
the beginning of July now that election
comes with a tweak and that is at the
winning party will get allocated more
seats making one-party rule more likely
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera Athens